Okay, so this is the other question about the true right. How does the new true right F122 compared to the older F122 and the F117 because there is a difference so I pulled up three pictures here. So this picture of the far left is the older F122. I think it came out in 2020 or 2021.
I can't remember.
Part for me with I can't remember past dates real well as far as years go.
And the middle picture is that F117 is a newer F117. And the one of the far right is the new F122 that they sell now.
Notice that there are some differences. Of course now the new one does not have these stupid little blue holders on the side of it.
On the side of it that Mike used to put on them that were handy when you'd wrap up the cord.
It was handy for things like that, but did make it look a little tackier and it nearly served no purpose for everyday use.
There was a time that probably nobody on this call can remember that the it did serve another purpose in that grounding port where I have these arrows pointing to this grounding port right there.
We used to use this handheld ground, especially when you were doing different things.
So when you were using the iron pro wave you had a grounding pillow that you'd plug into that ground or you'd have a grounding pad that you'd sit on and plug into that ground.
Notice on the new machines there's no grounding port there.
So you have to plug the ground the grounding pad or if you have a grounding pillow, you had to plug it into an outlet.
There's no considerable difference whatsoever there with that the reason why Mike initially put that grounding port in on the original F117 was because we used to use it with a handheld ground where people would actually hold and
ground while they're being treated. This is the years and years ago and that got phased out a long time ago.
But he kept the grounding port there to plug in the grounding pad it made perfect sense.
It also makes perfect sense to we don't really need that because that grounding port then actually went back to the ground of the cord that would then go to your grounded outlet.
So whether you plug it in here or you plug it in outlet it really doesn't make any difference.
So that is absence absent also the new F122 there's some things you can't do on it.
So you need to plug the grounding port your grounding pad into it outlet because there's no port there.
It does not support scanning so you guys don't know what scanning is.
There is a GRS scanner that Mike used to sell and we used to scan people in the office.
You scan for different frequencies. Now true I've doesn't even sell that scanner anymore.
Mike used to sell and I say Mike for those who are new who don't know who Mike has Mike used to be Mike used to own true right.
And just sold it the last year and a half but they don't even sell the GRS scanner anymore.
Mike used to sell a colloidal silver machine they don't sell that anymore Mike used to sell a an apparatus that you could connect little goggles to and put goggles on and run different frequencies that would stimulate different brain frequencies.
They don't sell that anymore so there's multiple different pieces that true right is just kind of phased out the new true right company is just kind of phased out.
And I know that that has made some people that were followers of Mike and true right through the years and helping support the different research that was done on frequencies and helping come up with different programs to use for different diseases.
It's kind of made them mad and the new company has kind of alienated a number of people and I've been trying to play the middle man and and calm people's heart style that that hey this is still a great company they're trying to do a lot of good things which I do believe is true.
I think they're doing a lot of good things they're trying to make improvements and just hang in there during any companies you know new changes there's always going to be some difficulties.
And you know there's going to be another question here that I'm going to address on another piece of what can be an issue with any new company and a company trying to make money these days that that's repairing things.
So they don't do a lot of repairs on things that in fact that's why the new true right folders are trying to get people to trade in their F122's because they don't want to have to repair them.
So where Mike was really good at trying to make repairs and things on things this company doesn't have the manpower to do it understand everything costs a lot more money now.
If you're going to have employees it costs a lot more money if you're going to have trade employees are not a fixed things like this it costs a lot more money.
And in order to not raise the prices I mean there's all sorts of reasons i'm not going to get in to defend it all those reasons but it just is what it is so they tried to get everybody to convert their F117's to F122's gave pretty steep deep discounts for people to trade in their old F11's.
So they wouldn't even be in the market anymore so people wouldn't be calling them wanting to get them repaired so I think the new F122's are an improvement I think they're constantly trying to make good changes and good improvement so I would say you know I'm still 100% behind this company but it those are the things that you just have to look at the differences.